in just a few hours republican lawmakers
in texas are expected to advance a bill
that democrats say would limit people's
ability to vote and that follows months
of protests and after state democrats
fled texas to block the proposal
republicans used baseless claims of
voter fraud to rally support for the
bill maria villarreal has been following
this and joins us from the state capitol
now maria good morning
well good morning tony intention is the
word that keeps coming to mind as we
have been here in austin texas right now
opponents of the bill say the new
restrictions would keep people from
disabilities would hurt people with
disabilities and people in black and
brown communities that live here in
texas they point for example to drive
through voting and overnight voting both
will be removed as this bill passes and
both were predominantly used by voters
of color right now democrats though are
still hopeful that they will be able to
attach amendments to the bill before it
passes here at the capitol
[Music]
got a right to live the fight over
voting rights in texas has been one of
the most contentious in the country more
than 50 democratic lawmakers fled the
state last month breaking quorum to
block gop backed bills they deem voter
suppression does it feel like then
anything was accomplished by breaking
quorum yeah something was accomplished
because it raised the awareness
representative garnett coleman's
district includes a portion of houston
why was it important for you to come
back last week i don't think we were
gaining anything by being away at some
point we have to fight on the floor
and
actually represent our constituents in
that way the bill bans drive-through and
24-hour voting increases id requirements
for mail-in ballots gives more powers to
partisan poll watchers and limits voter
assistance i expect a vigorous debate
house republican james white sponsored
the bill is this voter suppression are
we still talking about that some people
call it election integrity some people
call it suppression and i've worked with
them to get
desirable thing undesirable things out
of the bill so they can get it passed
coleman believes this fight stretches
beyond the state line the voting rights
act applies to
different places around the country
and the only way to do to have that is
for the u.s house and u.s senate to pass
the legislation
a lot of people feel the same way that
coleman does that the federal john lewis
voting rights act would be a way to keep
states from passing these voter
suppression laws like what's happening
here in texas right now the u.s house of
representatives have passed legislation
but it's expected to face an uphill
battle in the senate right now we know a
lot of lawsuits have been filed against
voting rights bills around the country
similar to what we are seeing here in
texas and those lawsuits are expected to
be filed here in texas when and if this
bill passes gail all right maria thank
you very much